since the beta and leading up to the
launch we kept hearing about how well
destiny 2 runs on PC now we have the
full release of the game and we've been
playing plenty of it we're gonna provide
some benchmark numbers and give you tips
on how to boost your framerate
[Music]
first let's run through some of the
important graphic settings in the
options menu we talked about these in
previous videos but it's key to bring
them up here again feel the view or fov
will widen your viewing angle allowing
you to see more on your peripheral
vision we recommend going with the max
at 105 as we did with all our tests this
does affect framerate since more of the
game world is being rendered on screen
we have two anti-aliasing options fxaa
tends to make the overall image a little
blurry and is less effective in getting
rid of jaggies as opposed to SMA which
does a better job but taxes your machine
a bit more in addition render resolution
or super sampling provides the cleanest
overall image but it will significantly
impact performance when set to high
percentages you should only use this if
you have plenty of FPS dispair texture
and I saw trippy or anisotropic
filtering makes textures and surfaces
seen at an angle and at a distance more
detailed it hardly impacts framerate so
we recommend setting this to 16 times
ambient occlusion darkens areas that
should be blocked from light sources to
add a richer look to the game HD AO does
a fine job of adding depth to the image
in exchange for a few FPS while 3d takes
us a step further it'll cost additional
fps texture quality should be set to the
highest since it won't impact
performance as long as you have enough
video memory on your graphics card the
menu also shows a bar to see how much
vram is being consumed so you'll know
shadow quality affects the resolution at
which shadows from the Sun and
spotlights are rendered this will
noticeably affect framerate the higher
its set while foliage shadow distance
doesn't affect performance all that much
foliage detail distance is a big-ticket
item if you need higher frame rates wind
impulse is a neat effect that makes
foliage realistically react to the
action in-game and it doesn't really
impact FPS light shafts affects the
quality of Ray casting through the
environment but doesn't ask much of your
system if it's turned up destiny too
doesn't allow you to use third-party
performance monitoring applications
which means we couldn't use fraps to
read our frame rates an in-game
benchmark tools also absent though we do
get a built in FPS counter by going off
of that we were able to track FPS at any
given moment during a sequence we
repeated to get our results we went to
Earth's European dead zone or etz but
got away from the Trostle and Church
outpost to make sure we had a controlled
environment we walked down the path to
the outskirts where the scenery opens
and Tessa PCs ability to render destiny
twos fast environments then we got in a
quick firefight with some dregs to
capture some action and we monitored the
framerate throughout the sequence the
system we use had an Intel Core i7 6700
K CPU at 4.2 gigahertz and 16 gigabytes
of RAM
we tested destiny 2 with three
resolutions using the latest video cards
from Nvidia and AMD that best fit each
resolution let's start with our 4k tests
it was ideal to do 4k with everything
maxed out on one card the gtx 1080i and
based on our test sequence the card
produced 51 to 60 FPS for a more
reasonable for case scenario we tweak
the settings and used HDA oh hi shadows
and no anti-aliasing we saw a noticeable
boost as the GTX 1080 T I gave 72 96 FPS
the GTX 1080 was able to get between 58
and 79 fps and AMD's RX Vega 64 gave us
54 to 73 fps moving on to the 2560 by
1440 resolution here we pitted the gtx
1070 and RX Vega 56 against each other
with every setting maxed out the 1070
produced between 60 and 88 FPS while the
Vega 56 got 54 to 77 fps bringing things
down a bit by using HD IO and high
shadows the gtx 1070 improved to 69 to
95 FPS and the Vega 56 bumped up to 61
to 87 fps I know we've been throwing
around a lot of numbers but hang in
there we're almost done for our 1080p
max test we matched the gtx 1060 and RX
580 they're pretty much neck and neck in
videos card gave us 65 to 92 fps and
AMD's card put out 64 to 89 fps by
turning the settings down to high and
using HD AO we can get great frame rates
on budget level cards we throw in the
gtx 1060 again and got between 76 and
101 FPS but the cheaper RX 570 yield at
63 290 FPS and the even cheaper gtx 1050
TI netted 52 72 FPS by doing tests on
both highest and high settings we see
how much of a boost in FPS there is
however there are four important options
to turn down when looking for better
frame rates ambient occlusion shadow
quality foliage detail distance and
depth of field taking these down a notch
contributed
getting lead to getting better
performance on our tests so look to
these settings if your system is
struggling turning fov down from 105 to
95 also gives a boost to FPS but test
this out to see if the narrower viewing
angle is a worthy trade-off to you every
other graphics option is pretty much
icing on the cake it's exciting to have
destiny 2 on PC especially since it runs
and plays like a true PC game we hope
you learned something about graphics
settings here or at least got some
contacts as to how the game performs
with some of the latest video cards at
the appropriate settings be sure to
check out our wealth of guides and
walkthroughs for the game on
gamespot.com if you're just getting
started and read or watch our full
review of destiny 2 if you're still
deciding on whether or not to jump in
thanks for watching and we'll see you
soon